une taille gnahou ce lieu insolite dans
lequel la mairie du perray-en-yvelines a
installé un centre de dépistage du coït
19 mobile cet équipement va parcourir
pendant un mois minimum 16 communes de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
et bien les gens vont souvent à trappes
ou parfois vont à rambouillet où il ya
de la tente
donc on a décidé nous mêmes de mettre en
place notre dispositif qui est assez
unique s'est adapté particulièrement à
la ruralité où personne aucune de nos
communes n'aurions pu avoir ce propre
centre de tests si nous n'avions pas eu
ni nos forces c'est tania housse prend
ses quartiers les mercredi et samedi sur
la place de la mairie du
perray-en-yvelines ce jour là il n'y
avait presque que des habitants de la
commune qui sont venus effectuer un test
pcr
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était une très
bonne initiative c'était très
intéressant de permettre plusieurs fois
par semaine au jour de la commune de
pouvoir venir se faire tester si
agréable spacieux aéré et puis les gens
sont super sympas aussi ce centre de
dépistage était aussi l'occasion de
sortir cette taille ni house qui dormait
sur un parking
depuis deux ans et acheté 30 mille euros
par la précédente municipalité
ça va en lien avec le prestataire loxam
inde deux aides soignantes ont la charge
de réaliser les tests mois avant que
j'arrive je doutais un peu
je savais pas ce que c'était donc jamais
fait dans ce genre d'endroit et
finalement c'est bien pratique environ
100 tests sont réalisés par jour un
dispositif faciliter aussi grâce aux
subventions de la région ile de france